[Music]
tonight on Brian Ross investigates in
the movies Kevin Costner is often the
lawman I have sworn to put this man away
with any and all legal means of my
disposal animal tissue but now an
explosive new lawsuit claims Koster in
real life broke the law with a secret
Swiss bank account something he denies
but the accusation comes from a former
Swiss banker who became America's most
rewarded whistleblower Bradley
Birkenfeld just because you're not
indicted doesn't mean you didn't break
the law he'll join us along with his
lawyer to tell us what he knows plus a
follow-up on our exclusive reporting on
the sex abuse scandal in USA Swimming I
cry a lot I lost my innocence now a
one-time u.s. swimming Olympic star is
coming forward with inside information
on how the sport covered up for guilty
coaches I did what I could and in
retrospect I wish I had been stronger I
wish I could topper and our shout out
for the person at the New York Times who
stood up to the threats from President
Trump the New York Times is totally
dishonest totally dishonest yeah I've
had a platform to stand up for
journalism and I'm proud to do that from
the law and crime Network Studios in New
York City's Herald Square this is Brian
Ross investigates good evening and
welcome tonight America's most rewarded
whistleblower strikes again former Swiss
banker Bradley Birkenfeld was paid more
than 100 million dollars by the US
government for blowing the whistle on
Americans who had secret bank accounts
in his Swiss bank UBS now in a new
lawsuit he names two more high-profile
Americans he says also had secret
accounts but were never identified
publicly it's an allegation they
strenuously deny in the movies Kevin
Costner is often cast as a man of the
law a man of integrity
schooled to put this man away with any
and all legal means of my disposal
Hamilton's Eliot Ness in the
Untouchables as the Wild West marshal
Wyatt Earp but in this new lawsuit
whistleblower Bradley Birkenfeld claims
kevin costner and billionaire
businessman Leonard Lauder the chairman
emeritus of Estee Lauder cosmetics had
secret accounts at the UBS bank in
Switzerland in the lawsuit Birkenfeld
names the bankers he says handled the
accounts of Costner and Lauder and he
says he provided both names among many
others to US authorities at the IRS and
the Department of Justice but Birkenfeld
claims that when he went to publish his
book
Lucifer's banker both Costner and Lauder
denied to the publisher that they had
the accounts and threatened legal action
against the publisher as a result
Birkenfeld claims in the lawsuit the
names of the two men were deleted from
the book and thousands of already
printed books had to be destroyed and
joining us now from Washington is Brad
Birkenfeld the whistleblower mr.
birkenthal thank you very much for being
here as you know both Kevin Costner and
Leonard Lauder strongly deny the claims
you make in your lawsuit are you certain
of your facts the attorneys filed this
lawsuit on the facts that I gave to the
Department of Justice the Internal
Revenue Service and the Securities and
Exchange Commission along with the u.s.
permanent Subcommittee on investigations
so when people read my complaint it
speaks for itself and I've tried to
whistle blow on this issue for over a
decade now and this lawsuit comes up
with the facts that were presented in
the lawsuit when you first made these
allegations before you went off to
prison you were convicted by the federal
government even after you provided all
that information you told me the same
thing and I at the time talked to the
Kevin Costner he could not have been
stronger in his denials he says there's
no laws there's no accountant UBS no
account overseas at all it's just not
true
it's a strong denial well I don't expect
him to admit my allegation we're going
to have to get into a court of law
to get to the truth that's what courts
do so I think
important for people to understand that
I worked at UBS during that time and I
worked with the gentleman who took care
of his account and he knows this for a
fact Stefan for her who was my colleague
at UBS in Geneva so I didn't just make
this up I told the truth to all of these
government agencies and if there was a
problem with that they would have
indicted me for lying which I did not
lie to the contrary I told the truth is
there any documentary proof can you tell
us how much was in the account how
active it was well I think we'll leave
that to the court trial and see what
happens with that I don't think I want
to prejudice the court the court filing
certainly my attorney can elaborate more
on that but we're we're looking forward
to getting to the truth as we've always
said and I've said this from the
beginning as a whistleblower that
exposed the largest and longest-running
tax fraud in the world we have a
question now from the control room from
executive producer Rondo Schwartz help
me Rhonda what's a good question for mr.
burke until bradley you have already
received 104 million dollars you
published a book why are you bringing
this up now why after all this time are
you coming back to this and bringing
this up again well Rhonda that's a
fantastic question and I think people
who know me understand that as a
courageous whistleblower that exposed as
they said the largest tax fraud in the
world at UBS and Switzerland now I have
to expose my own government the corrupt
Department of Justice who failed to do
their job but furthermore covered it up
so the very fact that they're supposed
to enforce the law but they end up
breaking the law shows that Americans
are fed up with this kind of nonsense in
government that's why I'm here in
Washington actually to expose more fraud
by the corrupt Department of Justice mr.
Burke and thought you said you gave all
this information to the Department of
Justice the IRS the Securities Exchange
Commission there's no record of them
taking any action against either Kevin
Costner or against Leonard Lauder who by
the way says yes there were accounts but
they were fully disclosed to the
government well I can't speak for the
incompetence at the Department of
Justice that mean there were 19,000
accounts at UBS and how many indictments
have we seen so how long does it take to
indict people when you have
on the silver platter over a decade ago
from the whistleblower who worked there
so everyone has said that I I told the
truth I gave them accurate information
it was timely and supportive to this
whole cause they were fine 780 million
dollars they closed the business down
and then of course they had to give up
4700 names which really wasn't all of
them so you begin to ask yourself why
didn't they find them properly why
didn't they get all 19,000 names
why haven't they indicted these people
because they're part of the problem not
part of the solution at the Department
of Justice
mr. Birkenfeld you have said to me
before you are seeking a pardon from the
president who overnight gave pardons to
two billionaires who he knows what's the
progress for you on that well I don't
know at this time I think once the
president he hears of my case and the
merits of my case about bringing more
than 20 billion dollars back to America
and from Swiss banks to American banks
closing down an illegal business and
making sure that a right is turned
upside down now because what has
happened here is they've they've accused
me the only banker and put me in jail
out of all the bankers that I exposed so
why should I be paying the price as the
whistleblower who exposed this and the
Department of Justice admits that they
could never have uncovered this without
me so it makes no sense whatsoever a
Bradley Birkenfeld thank you so much for
being here you're going to continue
presenting this lawsuit you're sticking
by your guns very quickly I stick by the
lawsuit my attorneys have filed it we
presented the facts to my lawyers they
vetted it and clearly I feel as though
the lawsuit speaks for itself and we
continue to push that lawsuit in federal
court Miami Bradley Birkenfeld a hundred
and four million dollar loss what
whistleblower congratulations on that
we'll talk to you soon
up next is an important update to our
exclusive report on the sex abuse
scandal at USA Swimming
now an update on our report here last
week about the sex abuse scandal at USA
Swimming a former Olympic gold medal
swimmer at one time insider at USA
Swimming is coming forward in reaction
to our report which detailed a dark side
to this sport a long sordid history of
swimming coaches sexually abusing
hundreds of young swimmers I feel guilty
all the time she was 14 when her
swimming coach began to sexually abuse
her and it physically and mentally hurts
not to cry her coach was 43 years old at
the time
Nathan weto described on the website of
the local Swim Club he owned as someone
who loves the sport of swimming and the
dedication it develops in young people
he turned me into somebody that no one
around me could recognize he groomed me
into somebody that I'm not well
ultimately confessed to what he had done
sighs kids I mean there are some
touching up the breasts and things like
that
the horses
yes Oh whose core oh not for the
officials who run USA Swimming it was
yet another threat to their well
cultivated public image a multi-million
dollar operations funded by large
corporate sponsors it oversees some
3,000 swim teams around the country
I play for future u.s. Olympics winnings
it's all about you know keeping
mercedes-benz and the corporate sponsors
and NBC happy and in a particular image
of Michael Phelps and Katie ledecky they
prioritized you know protecting the
brand winning a lot of medals and not
protecting the athletes but for all the
heroes an Olympic glory of USA Swimming
officials have known for more than a
decade about a very dark side hundreds
of young swimmers who were sexually
abused by their coaches cases including
one of the country's top swim coaches
Shaun Hutchinson who was banned last
year after Olympic medalist Arianna
Cukor went public with allegations he
had abused her organizations like USA
Swimming have long been in a position to
deter detect and discipline sexual abuse
and have done little or nothing to do
such in an effort to protect their
public image by doing nothing it enabled
Shaun Hutchison to abuse me for a decade
in fact the USA Swimming website
includes a list of almost 200 coaches
who have been suspended or banned from
the sport because of allegations or
convictions for sexual abuse that list
now includes Nathan Weddell of North
Carolina the president and CEO of USA
Swimming Tim Hinchey declined repeated
requests to talk with us and when we
showed up at USA Swimming's annual gala
fundraiser in New York he would not tell
us why only a tiny percentage the
group's 3,000 swim teams have been
certified his so-called
safe sports clubs
how many recognize safes sport-club
fixes today can you answer that question
sir
mr. Hinchey really
and we're joined now by David birkoff
the winner of four Olympic medals as a
USA swimmer
two of them gold and for years someone
on the inside of the USA Swimming
governing body he's now a lawyer in
Missoula Montana and joins us from there
Thank You mr. birkoff for being here
none of this surprises you at all does
it no it doesn't and what's been going
on that this has been covered up and is
only now really still coming out you
know i-i've been thinking about that
over a number of years and I I it's hard
to explain I don't know if this is a an
issue unique to swimming or to amateur
sports but I think it's partially to
blame to our culture which avoids
conflict avoids facing hard problems and
hard issues in any constructive way and
unfortunately in this case with abuse
victims in my sport that I love so much
crying we had lots and lots of kids who
suffered the consequences of our leader
is not leading the way they should
you've told me over the years you tried
to do something and nobody would listen
is that accurate I'd say the majority of
people who are in positions of power
back in the early 90s when I was still
an athlete and I preface this by saying
that in their early 90s late 80s the
athletes had little to no power the
athletes have a lot more say and what
happens in USA Swimming and other
amateur sports now that they've been
professionalized but back in the 90s
when I suggested that we enact a code of
conduct and a process for removing bad
coaches from our ranks it was basically
mothballed and nothing happened and
this abuse this sexual abuse of young
swimmers mostly females going on and
sort of known you would hear Scala and
what really prompted me to do what I did
back in 1992 was a reaction to hearing
from some of the u.s. the US team
members and Texas or ours
about the alleged abuse of Kelly Davies
and never met Kelly I didn't know his
coat or her coach
but I heard these rumors and they were
to me extremely offensive and I didn't
think that coaches who were
predisposition to abuse athletes should
be in this floor
yuria and yet and get that coach thing
in swimming for a long time yeah and I
was at the I think 2008 Olympic Trials
by two of my family and I saw Rick curl
walk one of the Olympic team members
down the back and I said what the hell
is he doing and as you know Kelly Davis
and her lawyer have in part blamed you
that you should have done more what do
you say to that you know I think it's
easy for MS Davies and her lawyer to
blame me but you got to remember when I
was 25 years old I was still an athlete
and I was up against 67 year-old men who
were in control of an organization and
didn't really want to hear from this
young whippersnapper who who was giving
them you know kicking little theories of
what's going to happen to the
organization I did what I could and in
retrospect I wish I had been stronger I
wish I had been tougher and I wish I
could have helped but as a young person
who had no money and was in graduate
school and it really didn't feel like he
was being listened to
there's only so much I can do does that
I want you to this day I don't know if
it haunts me
because there were many many other
people
who had first-hand knowledge including
her former coaches and her best friends
and in fact her parents who knew about
the abuse and didn't do didn't do as
much as they could have
having that first-hand knowledge again I
I've never met Kelly I've never met I've
never even spoken to Rick Earl
and yet I tried to do something you know
we can look at things in in hindsight
with 20/20 vision and say boy I wish I
was a stronger human and really fought
for this but at the time it was an
uphill battle and I was running out of
energy and as you know now there have
been almost 200 coaches banned for life
or at least suspended
that's a terrible record this problem
has not ended has it I think there's a
double answer to that I think yes you're
right 200 people on the banned list it
shows that there is a clear problem and
the fact that many of those if not a
majority of those people added to the
banned list were added after 2010 when
we've enacted our first safe sport rules
what that tells me is that we need to do
more and we can't apply the brakes now
as an organization as a sport we need to
be vigilant and we need to do whatever
it takes to keep kids from being abused
by coaches or officials or even fellow
swimmers
well David birkoff thank you so much for
joining us tonight when we come back our
shout out to the point person at the New
York Times who doesn't get a byline
hasn't won a Pulitzer Prize but actually
invited Donald Trump's lawyer to sue the
paper and get a lesson in how the First
Amendment works we welcome the
opportunity to have a court set him
straight
shout out tonight for someone who is not
a journalist but has helped set a tone
of erudite resistance in an era when
attacks on journalists have come from
many directions but none more ugly than
from the White House this is someone who
works at what the president calls the
failing and New York Times my name is
David McCraw I am the deputy general
counsel at the New York Times company
and my primary responsibility is
anything that comes out of the newsroom
that presents a legal problem David
McCoy has never won a Pulitzer Prize or
even had a New York Times byline but I
told him that in newsrooms around the
country he is seen as a hero in an era
of journalism under attack I'm not sure
I'm gonna buy into the hero label but
certainly I've had a platform to stand
up for journalism and I'm proud to do
that it has put him head-to-head with
Donald Trump
the New York Times is totally dishonest
totally dishonest I think the main thing
that concerns me has been the attempt by
the President and others to delegitimize
the press it really is an invitation to
distrust to not believe you are fake
news you are the enemy of the people you
look at the network so you look at the
news you look at the newscasts I call it
fake news I draw a line between that and
criticism with the press press should be
criticized any institution should but
this idea of just to dismiss it as fake
news enemy of the people I think has
been deadly do you think Donald Trump
who believes that I think he knows that
it plays well to a political base I
don't know whether he really thinks that
is a true fact and the New York Times is
failing if I weren't here I believe the
New York Times probably wouldn't even
exist when he continues to refer at the
time there's the failing New York Times
what's the reaction inside this building
it's a little amusing because as you
know he also talks about how he saved
the New York Times because subscriptions
went through the roof when he was
elected and that's really closer to the
truth in his new book truth in our times
McCrory calls perhaps his finest hour as
he came to the defense of the New Year
chimes report about two women who
claimed Trump had physically groped them
he was like an octopus it was like he
had six arms he was all over the place
Trump than a candidate annually denied
the allegation
now we address the slander and libel
that was just last night thrown at me by
the Clinton machine and the New York
Times and other media outlets as part of
a concerted coordinated and vicious
attack and overnight Trump's lawyer
demanded the Times retract its story and
issue an apology saying quote failure to
do so will leave my client with no
option but to pursue all available
actions and remedies I felt that we
needed to have a strong response the
response was this letter from the craw
no retraction essentially see you in
court we did what the law allows we
published newsworthy information about a
subject of deep public concern if mr.
Trump disagrees if he believes that
American citizens had no right to hear
what these women had to say and the law
of this country forces us and those who
would dare to criticize him to stand
silent or be punished we welcome the
opportunity to have a court set him
straight the letter went viral in the
end I think the people two times were
very happy that I'd done it this way and
I'm fortunate to work in a company that
was going to stand behind me for a
response is strong so our shout out
tonight for David McCraw defender of the
First Amendment that's our program for
tonight thanks for joining us we'll see
you back here next week good night